un monasterio prístino junto al río
tonet es una imagen perfecta casi aquí
en seattle hearts en el norte del
donbass la línea del frente no está
lejos soldados rusos están a unos 10 km
eso está
escrito por el monasterio no puede haber
un ataque masivo para mí sería imposible
quedarme con estos monstruos si vinieran
pero mientras nuestros soldados estén
aquí me quedaré
época
la calle
el monasterio desviado horse está bajo
la jurisdicción del patriarcado de moscú
o sea la iglesia ortodoxa rusa la idea
de que moscú lo atacara era inimaginable
para muchos residentes pero lleva las
cicatrices de un ataque con misiles un
militar local explicó de forma anónima
que este lugar sagrado es una espina
para el ejército ucraniano observa trata
ni música este monasterio no es en
absoluto la casa de dios dios dijo no
matarás dios no elige bandos debería ser
un lugar para todos pero este monasterio
ha elegido bandos y lo ha hecho desde
2014 fuentes de todas sean los
extranjeros de dichos tratos desde la
invasión rusa muchos residentes en el
este de ucrania han huido al oeste en
ese viaje o hertz algunos residentes
prefirieron refugiarse en rusia y varios
de los que quedaron no ven al ejército
de moscú como una amenaza
están eligiendo el lado ruso algunos de
ellos piensan que cuando los rusos
ataquen y avancen ellos estarán a salvo
detrás de las líneas rusas
esta mujer no oculta sus opiniones
prorrusa
nuevas y rehabilitadas iconos fue
ucrania la que provocó a rusia el
presidente podría haber detenido las
provocaciones hay que decir la verdad
basta con mirar a europa y eeuu unidos
contra rusia si fueras el líder que
haría si todos rodearán a tu país como
depredador es fútil no está aquí para
entrometerse sino para defender el
donbass
de
sports está dividida algunos darán la
bienvenida a los soldados rusos sin
reparos pero otros esperan que los
militares ucranianos puedan mantener
este puente uno de los últimos que
quedan en pie en la región